so how do we know that there's a core
and that the core is made up of a liquid
outer core and a solid inner core and
the answer there comes from the same
technique that we saw mejor Ovie cheeked
use in 1909 to essentially see how the
behavior or when you measure the seismic
waves or whether you can even measure
the seismic waves the different
distances from an earthquake so if
there's an earthquake right here and
we're talk calling that zero degrees
let's remember a couple of things here
let's remember that P waves P waves can
travel through anything they can travel
through solid or liquid or air for that
matter so they can travel through
anything anything but S waves can only
ask for secondary S waves can only these
are the transverse waves these can only
only travel through solids so it turns
out that if an earthquake happens at
zero degrees and you had seismograph
stations all over the world and these
are extremely sensitive in order to be
able to measure earthquakes that are
happening thousands of kilometers away
it turns out that there's something
called an S shadow you can an S wave a
shadow you can measure if these are S
waves you can measure them here you can
measure them here they can go all the
way over here they can go over here
they can go over there you can measure
them over here you could so you can
measure them at all of these points but
then all of a sudden all of a sudden at
105 degrees and so we're measuring zero
degrees here and we're going outwards
like that all of a sudden at 105 degrees
and further you stop measuring S waves
they don't get for some reason you would
think that some that the S waves would
get over here they would get over here
maybe they would be a little bit weaker
but they would be able to get all the
way over here but they just abruptly
stop no more S waves so in this whole
area right over here
you get no S waves you get no S waves
and obviously I could flip this picture
over and you would see a symmetric thing
on the other side of the globe that all
of all of this area over here you also
would not see you would also not see S
waves you would only see them all from
105 degrees in this direction and 105
degrees in that direction and the only
reasonable explanation that
can give is that there must be some
material that an s-wave cannot travel
through that it would have to travel
through to get to these points beyond
105 degrees and we know that s waves
only travel in solids so the assumption
there is that saw at some point beyond
105 degrees it's hitting liquid so
that's what tells us this right here is
probably this right here is probably a
liquid it's hitting some layer that is
liquid so that tells us that there's a
core and at least the outer part of that
core is liquid enough to stop enough to
stop S waves so the S waves because it
only travels in solids it leads to this
S wave S wave shadow and this tells us
that we have a core that we have a core
and that core at least the outer part is
liquid we don't know we we don't know
yet whether the inner part is liquid or
solid now the next point of engine is
how do we know that there's an inner
corner we can use P waves for that the P
wave a few wave can travel through
anything but remember as you get denser
material as you get in general for the
same type of material if you get denser
material it's going to move faster
source we're gonna refract outwards like
we've seen over here but if it goes into
a liquid in general sound waves or I
should say P waves seismic waves move
slower moves slower in liquids and so
the refraction patterns we get when we
do measure from seismograph stations
around the world is that it looks like
the P waves are there kind of doing this
what you would expect in the mantle but
then they're getting refracted as if
they're going into a slower medium as
they go through the outer core and we
see that right over here and then they
get refracted again to get to some point
on the other side now that is just what
you would expect if it was all liquid
but if you go to kind of if you go to
stations that are even further out it
looks like if you just look at the
refraction patterns and you can now
model this with fancy computers and get
all the data points but you could say
well the only way to the only way that
reality can fit the data that we get
based on when things reach here is if
the P waves are being first refracted
through the outer core but then there
are four
a fracture in a way that they're going
through denser material significantly
denser material in the inner core in the
inner core and then they're just
continuing to refract the way you would
expect so it's really the refraction
pattern of the p-waves and frankly the
fact that there's this what you call a
p-wave shadow the p-wave shadow by
itself all that tells you is that kind
of roughly crazy things are happening
someplace in the core but the real way
to know that we have an inner core
that's solid as opposed to the whole
thing being liquid is that the p-waves
is the pattern of when and how the
p-waves
reach essentially the other side of the
globe then you can kind of based on
modeling how how waves would travel
through different densities and
different types of mediums you could say
well there's gotta be an inner core
right over here and obviously it's a lot
more math than I'm going into but if you
if you do the math based on the shadow
and you know the speed of the material
and all of that type of thing then you
can figure out the the the the depth at
which these transitions occur we know
that we have a transition from mantle to
outer core here and then a transition
from outer core to core there so
hopefully that that satiates your
questions about how do we know what the
composition of the earth is without ever
having digging without without having to
dig down there because we've never even
gotten below our crust